Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr in,
it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March 25th,
2013 just like that.
It's the end of the third month.
We're almost a quarter of the way through the,
where is it going?
Um,
I'm sitting downstairs in my,
uh,
I,
you know,
I don't even know if it's a room right now.
I don't know if you can call it a room,
you know.
Ah,
I'm so fucking sick of this bullshit.
I swear to God I'm ready to just give it to the insurance companies and just be
like,
you know what dude?
What do you do?
You want to stick in there?
How recycled toothpicks all mashed together with some Elmers glue.
F fucking stick it in there.
Alright.
You dicks.
Like,
I didn't know you were going to do this to me the day I fucking got insurance
from you guys.
You know,
we reviewed your policy and we actually found some areas.
They always fucking do that.
God dammit fucking pussy ass insurance adjuster,
right?
The guy comes here,
you know,
and he's all fucking smiles and rosy cheeks throwing stripper glitter all over
the fucking room air.
We're going to cover everything.
Don't you worry about a law shield?
We're going to plug them beep up,
up to Boopa.
[inaudible] right.
And then what happens when the hammer comes down?
Is he looking me in my eye?
Is he standing in my living room with outside air blowing through his fucking
hair?
Cause I have no fucking roof.
No.
How does he do it?
He calls me up.
Leaves a fucking message.
That's what he does.
You have to come on over here like Chris fucking kringle he calls up.
Alright.
Like some fucking college age dude who doesn't,
not a breakup with his chick.
So we just does it over the phone.
Right,
because he doesn't want to deal with the waterworks.
You didn't want to see me break down and cry.
You know,
as he tells me that he reviewed my policy and Oh wait a minute,
I'm not as covered as as I thought I was.
You know,
and then he'd see my bottom lip start quivering
and he'd see my shoulders start shaking.
Right?
He didn't want to be there for that ugly mess.
It's bad enough when a bra starts crying,
forget about a grown man.
Did I just say grown man?
That's one of the expressions.
I can't stay on the motion comedy girl.
I'm a grown man.
How many fucking we know we could see it.
You have a beard,
you asshole.
This happened and then this happened and I'm like,
Hey,
wait a minute.
You know I'm a grown ass man.
Oh really?
Has nothing to do with comedy.
You know it has to do with the,
you let that's plastic on the downstairs bed.
Why do I have plastic on the bed?
You're probably wondering what's the matter bill?
What'd he have?
Bed Wetter.
Is that what it is?
So the pressure,
we're going out on stage starting to get to you.
You starting to Pete,
you starting to Piss the bed?
That kid?
Yeah,
they got this fucking plastic down here cause all the shit was that was in the
other room is now on the fucking bed.
God knows what's in my hockey jerseys
here.
Probably some combination of a speced this with some Ma.
You know I was a little dusting of lead paint and um,
you know,
it's overrated.
Fucking worrying about lead paint.
Okay.
Rich,
really fucking overrated.
All this lead paint fucking removal.
I guess when you're knocking down walls,
you don't want to breathe this shit in.
But other than that,
if you got lead paint and your walls,
it's in the walls.
It's fucking in the walls,
man.
What's it gonna do to you?
What's up lead paint?
Fuck you got,
I mean,
what's it gonna do to you?
You can walk around licking your walls.
How old are you?
I guess if you have a kid.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
But,
but if you're a grown ass grown ass,
man,
I'm not going to be fucking stick my tongue in my God damn walls,
even though I can stick my head through my fucking con.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
I'll tell you,
you're really fall out of love with your house when you can see inside the
fucking walls and you just see all this shit that's covered up.
You know what I mean?
It's like when you date and some hot broad,
and you're thinking you're starting to catch feelings.
And then there's that one day where she just fucking answers the door and you
see what she really looks like.
That right there.
If you still got that tingling your chest,
you love that woman.
All right,
I've got to tell you,
the tingles gone.
Uh,
guys,
I had to work guys.
Oh my God guys.
I just had
another pet peeve of mine people.
Red Dress audience is guys,
guys,
just listen.
Cibele what do you like?
Oh,
I don't know.
Having a fucking wall
in between my rooms.
That's something I enjoy.
Oh,
I'm in a mood,
so whatever.
So this is my deal,
right?
I'm in this fucking mood.
Man's home is his castle,
right?
And mine has a big battering fucking rammed pulse through the God damn thing.
So it's affecting my mood when I go out in public.
All right,
so here's the deal.
Um,
uh,
I had two shows this weekend,
one in Indianapolis and uh,
and to in,
in Minneapolis it was a mini apolis tour that I was on.
MMM.
And what,
what the fuck did I do?
I know.
So Thursday I'm taking the red eye out.
I did an episode of this show called the crow show starring Necro and that dude
is fucking out of his mind.
He's absolutely hilarious.
Had a great time all day.
You know,
we were shooting in this house that had walls and a roof.
it was funny,
it was actually where we were shooting was the home of the person who started
the cheesecake factory,
which I thought was really funny cause I've trashed that place I think in all
three of my specials if I didn't do it.
And all three of my specialists,
I know I didn't at least one.
And I was thinking about it and the other two because I fucking hate that place.
And um,
it is one,
I actually thought that,
uh,
I thought a guy started it right,
but it's actually a lady.
Can you believe that some woman started a restaurant that went,
went national?
I see.
I,
I didn't think that they could do stuff like that.
You know,
I thought like when a,
when a woman started a restaurant,
it was just like,
you know,
or husband paid for it.
Right.
And it was right down there on main street.
There wasn't making any money,
but it kept her busy,
you know,
and everybody came in and bought her fucking gluten free cupcakes.
You know,
just keep her happy.
No,
this fucking,
you should have seen this goddamn house.
Sting was,
it was insane.
And you know what?
You could tell,
you could tell that it was one of many challenges.
The cheesecake factory.
Do you want just for those of you who aren't in the United States,
okay.
If you sell cheesecake selling cheese,
the amount of fat Fox that are in this country,
okay.
And don't get too cocky.
People in other countries.
I'm coming around to you later.
Okay?
Don't act like you don't have any fucking dirty laundry though.
You're racist.
Fucking soccer fans.
It would see when they painted the fucking crowd and it's,
sorry.
Half the people in the stands have Hitler mustache.
They're the most racist,
ugliest,
fucking white people you've ever seen in your life,
you know?
Okay.
Why do I think they're all white?
You know why?
Because I fucking watched the premiere league every once in a while,
you know,
but I can't keep up with it because they changed.
Did their fucking jerseys.
They don't have colors.
Well they don't stick with them.
You'll have a team that's red and white and then one day they'll show out with
like,
like show up with like black,
black and yellow jerseys and I got fucking writing all over them all like a
stock car.
I can't find them.
It should just say man United it.
You just say Liverpool arsenal.
Just have fucking that.
You guys got everything this.
You just run down the fucking pitch with a god Damn Sandwich Board on,
you know,
eat at ames,
mate.
She shuffled fucking pork chop.
Um,
plastic
fucking driving me nuts do it.
I swear to God.
You know,
if anybody wants to pull up my house,
I swear to God.
So let me pull up my house right now and often be 40 bucks for it.
I would walk.
It's all yours buddy.
Here's the case.
Kitchen's in the back and I go fuck yourself.
That's it.
Get my socks and underwear.
A couple of tee shirts and some sweatpants and that's it.
I live in my Prius.
MMM.
So when it yet selling cheesecake
salad,
cheesecake and America is like selling fish and chips and fucking Great Britain.
I mean,
do you realize how bad you have to fuck up that dish to not make any God damn
money?
It's brilliant.
She sells,
she sees,
she saw the market.
She was sitting there going,
you know,
there's a lot of fed fucks in this country.
What a fat fucks like cake.
MMM.
I actually not,
I swear I'm going to keep an eye on that relationship.
I don't know who she is,
but I swear to God if that fucking piece of shit that she's married too.
I love how,
I'm assuming that he's a piece of shit.
Let's just say she married a piece of shit.
If that do goes to divorce her all right.
And he teached,
Ti takes,
you know,
he basically does what every broad does to a fucking rich guy.
I swear to God.
Okay,
what do you swear to God?
But what are you going to do?
I don't know what I'm gonna do.
You know what,
I will,
I'll probably have a 15 minute bit on that guy
on how horrific it is.
What kind of a man are you that you would do that?
And then secondly,
after all these other men have been going absolutely fucked in the ass and these
divorce settlements that you could switch to the other side like that and we can
our fucking position,
right?
Cause then they'll have the example.
Well what about the fucking Douche bag?
Who took all the money from the,
uh,
the,
the cheesecake lady,
that cheese cake lady.
Okay.
I pay people like Oreos and like cake.
What if we stuck a both in one?
And what if we had people that we didn't really pay a lot of money.
It was a factory,
just a factory cheesecake.
That really is a really,
uh,
not an appetizing name.
Cheesecake factory.
Does that sound like there's any love in that cake?
They just pumping them out.
People were fucking
just dead eyes staring straight ahead getting carpal tunnel cause their job's to
put the Cherry on top all fucking day long.
You know,
get Tennis Elbow,
putting cherries on top of cakes.
You couldn't even look your dad in the eye after that.
If he had that job,
he looked down at the floor,
you know,
all proud talking about his whole family until he came to you.
And what about Steven?
What Steven doing?
Uh,
yeah,
he's got to get a job down the road.
Job Down the road.
What seat was he paving the roads where we Mikey,
you're getting all vague here.
What's going on?
And you know,
his friends I already knew or he knew that his son put cherries on top of cakes
all day.
You know,
and guys at Dixon rather just getting right to it.
They got a torch or the guy down the road down the road where down the road at
the cheesecake factory.
What does he do?
He put the sprinkles on them.
Come on,
Mikey would just kidding.
No,
no,
that's good.
That's good.
Hey,
it's one of his arms.
A lot bigger than the other one could from lifting all those cherries all day
long.
Okay.
Um,
anyways,
I'm sorry.
I wanted to get to the point of this podcast here.
The point of this podcast is to make you laugh in a fucking whore myself out.
So you'll come out to my shows and I don't think I've been doing a very good
job.
So right now I'm going to be deliberately funny for the next nine seconds.
All right.
No.
Oh my God,
you guys,
I have to tell you the story.
So I'm flying.
So I do what episode of Kroll Show?
Um,
and always working with Nick Kroll.
You're guaranteed you're going to laugh your ass off off fucking deck.
Can I kiss the kids ass?
I fucking love him.
I think he's,
I think he's a fucking genius.
So anyways,
um,
I go,
I go to the airport and I'm taking the redeye taking this 10 55 flight,
nine fucking stop.
Cause that's how I do it.
All right.
I'm on a good plane.
Why would I want to get off it and switch and roll the dice and get on another
one?
You know,
let's just fucking get there
when it,
when I drive up to San Francisco,
I don't pull over and fucking,
uh,
Burbank and then get hit new another cup.
We get it bill.
All right,
so I get on the fucking plane,
right?
I use my miles,
bump myself up like a fancy person.
You know,
maybe,
maybe I invented the cheesecake factory.
People are thinking and then they see how I'm dressed and I go,
oh no,
he didn't invent the cheesecake factory.
Um,
and I go to go to sit down on my seat and I go to set my bag down.
I was going to set it down right in front of me.
And the Nice fellas sit next to me,
he goes,
why don't you stick it in the middle of this room?
And he moved his bag out of the way.
I'm like,
all right,
this guy's a solid dude or whatever.
And then all of a sudden the waitress comes by a stewardess,
whatever.
She comes by,
um,
flight attendant,
whatever the fuck you supposed to call them.
She comes up and she,
uh,
could I get you a job with a Drake?
And I was like,
yeah,
can I get out?
I'm,
let me get a water please.
I said,
no.
Ice.
What?
However you make it.
Stop acting like it's a fucking Martini.
It's war,
right?
Just give me a water with ice.
Thank you.
MMM.
And the,
the guy next to me,
he orders it doers.
Neat.
No Way.
No nothing.
Just put it in there.
So they bring our drinks.
All right.
And I'm really thirsty.
So I start sucking mind down and he just throws his back.
Like,
it's nothing like fucking John Wayne right before he's going to turn around and
beat up three guys,
three mustachioed guys in the 1930s.
Right?
So,
um,
I'm just sitting there and everybody's getting on the flight and out and I'm
looking around at the passengers,
you know,
fucking doing whatever I'm doing.
And all of a sudden the guy next to me,
Mr Doers,
goes to me,
uh,
he goes,
excuse me?
He goes,
are you afraid to fly?
And I looked and I was like,
what?
He goes,
are you afraid to fly?
And I go,
no,
I'm not.
And he goes,
because all right,
but you know,
it's,
he goes,
it's okay.
It's okay to tell me if you're afraid to fly.
And immediately getting,
and I'm like,
no,
I'm not afraid to fly.
And then I'm thinking in my head,
wait,
is he afraid to fly?
And that's why he's drinking the way he just drank.
And now he's hoping that I'm going to be afraid to fly.
So he,
you know,
he just wants to open up.
That's what I'm thinking.
And I go,
Mike,
yeah,
no,
I'm not afraid to fly.
And he won't leave it alone.
He goes,
all right,
cause you know,
you're,
you're fidgeting,
you're looking around at other passengers.
And I'm sitting there looking at it like,
is this guy fucking serious?
And I go,
now I go,
I'm not afraid to fly.
So now I'm like,
fuck this guy.
I'm not talking this guy for the rest of the flight.
This guy's weird,
man.
It's like 30.
Just get paint the pictures like 32 year old winery in shape,
but like,
why are we white dude,
he's got a skully cap on with fucking glasses.
Um,
you know,
and uh,
he goes,
uh,
like there's like a minute of silence and people still getting on the plane.
And then he goes,
hey,
sorry about that.
Sorry.
We just,
we just got off on the wrong foot.
He's like,
my name's So-and-so.
He goes,
what's your name?
And then I'm thinking in my head like,
what's my name?
My name's frank.
I wanted to give them like a f by just some reason I just wanted it's bill.
And he goes,
Oh hey bill.
nice to meet you.
So we shake hands and I'm just looking at,
I don't have any poker face.
I'm looking at the guy like,
what the fuck is your problem?
I'm not even trying to not,
I'm not trying to be pleasant.
I'm already done with this guy.
So then the guy goes,
oh hey bill.
He goes,
why are you going to Indianapolis Bill?
Right?
Like he's fucking interrogating me and I,
okay.
I'm like,
is this guy fucking serious?
And I start doing the math in my head going,
when is this guy like an air marshal is something.
And I'm like,
no,
he's not.
He's fucking slamming bows over here.
Fuck this guy.
So I just go,
I go,
look,
I don't,
I don't have to answer your questions.
That's it.
And I just look straight forward.
He goes,
okay,
now I'm concerned.
Okay,
I am concerned.
And I'm looking at them like concerned about what he goes,
you're fidgeting your,
you,
you have issues with other passengers and blah,
blah,
blah.
He's such a Peyton like,
like this.
Like he's been,
I don't know what the fuck,
like psychologically breaking me down.
All right,
so now at this,
by this point,
they've closed the fucking the door to the fuselage and we're starting to taxi.
And I just finally look at the guy and I,
and I go,
I go,
you know,
I came up with the five one point.
I literally stick my hand out cause he kept saying I was nervous and I stick my
hand right in front of his face and I hold it level.
Oh,
that's what I did the first time.
Yeah.
I hold it level.
I go,
I'm not nervous.
And he goes,
well,
anybody can do that.
And that's when I was like,
fuck this guy.
I'm not talking to the guy.
Sorry.
Fuck the story up.
Then Denny Denny came back,
got my name.
Now he's going,
why are you going to Indianapolis?
And I find,
look at them.
I say,
listen pal,
I'm drinking waters.
You're drinking doers.
Okay,
there's no issue over here.
And then he goes,
it wasn't doers.
What she gave me wasn't doers really.
What was it?
Some sort of spy juice,
you fucking jerk off this point.
I want to punch him right through his fucking stupid wirey glasses,
right?
So he's going like,
you're looking around hostels.
And I said something that just ticked him off.
I was just saying,
dude,
I go,
I don't have to answer your questions.
All right,
leave me alone.
And then he goes,
uh,
he goes to egos.
He starts going like,
okay,
now I am really concerned right now.
He goes,
why are you going to Indianapolis?
And I just look at him,
you know,
when I stopped doing,
I start doing like this Ryan Gosling,
you know that little smirk that fucking Mona Lisa smile he has is he smirks his
way through all this fucking movies.
I do go.
I go full on Ryan Gosling.
Now I'm not talking to this guy and I just keep looking at him and I give them
that little half a smirk and I just shake my head.
That's my game now that's,
this is Mike.
It's like if you're going to be a Dick Right now with your fucking delusional
authority,
right?
That you're going to like,
we're in fucking Guantanamo and you're got to waterboard me,
Huh?
There's no water,
there's no board.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Here's my smart and I'm just going to shake my head at you like you're a fucking
pathetic human being.
This is what I'm doing,
right?
And this is the funny thing.
I'm such a Dick.
All they have to say to the guys,
I'm a comedian,
I'm going to do a sold out show there and that would make them back off,
but I'm a dick.
I'm like,
fuck this guy.
I want to see where this is going to.
Now he's all fucking amped up and he starts dropping f you see saying the f
word.
He sit in and go to funeral.
He goes,
if you don't fucking answer my question right fucking now I'm going to hit that
call button was sitting there,
taxi and down the fucking getting in line,
I'm going to fucking hit this fucking button if you blah blah,
blah,
blah.
And I'm just fucking Mona Lisa smile smirking to shaking my head like you are a
fucking retard,
right?
So now he sees saying the f word so much.
The Lei who's sitting in front of me diagonally in front,
right in front of him,
turns around and looks at us,
and now my heart's racing.
I'm like,
where's this going?
This is going to be great.
I am a hundred percent fucking innocent.
This guy's drunk and I think he's going to hit that button.
He's going to hit that button.
What's going to happen?
Right?
I want to see what the pilot looks like.
Let's see where the fuck this is going,
right?
So he goes,
if you fuck you,
he starts getting such.
Bring his hand up to the button going,
I'm going to hit that button.
You have to go fucking do it.
I'll hit that button and I'm sitting there smirking and I'm thinking in my head,
go ahead and hit the fucking button.
Let's see what happens.
Let's see what happens,
right?
So finally,
now he wants to hit the button and he can't fucking find it and it's an in
defense of him.
I couldn't find it either.
I was looking up there.
I have one to hit it myself.
Then he finally,
he finally finds it and he hits it right?
And now I'm just like,
Holy Shit,
what's going to happen?
And he's sitting there going,
yeah,
Huh,
you want to fucking play this game and you want to fucking play this game?
And I'm surprised.
I mean it took like fucking like 30 seconds before a flight attendant,
the one who gave him the booze,
which evidently wasn't booze comes over.
And at this point we're like doing that shit where we're behind the plane,
we're almost ready to take off,
like we're pulling up and then stop and pull it up and stopping as planes are
taking off.
So she goes,
yeah,
what's the problem over here?
And he goes,
ah,
I'm not comfortable to fly with this guy.
This guy,
he's fidgeting,
he's looking around at other fucking people,
blah,
blah.
He's doing all this thing right?
And then the stewardess looks at me and I'm just sitting there fucking my little
smart,
just shaking my head that just looking at this dude just shaking my head like
this guy's out of his fucking mind.
I don't say a word.
And this guy goes on and on and on about his fucking psycho babble about how I'm
the security risk.
So she goes to,
so she goes,
okay.
Um,
any other passengers?
Have you noticed anything?
She talks to everybody first class.
This
is there.
Anybody noticed anything odd about this guy and the lady who was sitting right
in front of the dude diagonally from me turns around.
She goes,
yeah,
I've been listening to this guy,
bright berating this other passenger.
She's on my side and I haven't said a fucking word.
This is a great,
and I'm just sitting there smirking.
Then they'll let students looks to me and I shrugged my shoulders like,
I don't know what to tell you.
It's a finally she said,
sir,
do you have anything to add to this?
And I just said,
look,
I'm just a guy trying to go to Indianapolis.
This guy over here,
he starts slamming his doors.
I kind of felt like a rat when I said that.
I go,
he's slamming his doors.
Next thing you know,
he's dropping the F bomb to me.
Then I'm thinking,
oh fuck.
I just said bomb.
Right.
Fortunately nothing happens.
So now another fucking,
the male stewardess comes over right now,
he's going like,
what's going on?
And the captain of the fucking now at this point,
we pulled over in the plane,
has stopped 250 people trying to get to Indianapolis and jerk off over here,
can't hold his fucking alcohol,
who just watched a person of interest every,
every August.
Evidently I have no fucking idea.
Now the plane is stopped,
is fucking jerk off,
has stopped the plane interrogating a Goddamn comedian.
Like I'm in the fucking Taliban and like he works for the CIA,
right?
So now we're just sitting there,
the captain is upfront in the plane,
like saying to the storage is going basically relaying,
do I really have to fucking come back there?
This is the last flight of the night.
Is there really a God damn problem?
And that was the vibe.
And they finally said to the dose,
sit next to me.
Are you going to be okay to fly with him?
And at that point it appeased his fucking ego that he was somehow in control.
And he goes like,
you know what?
Okay.
It's fine.
It'll be fine.
So they go,
okay.
So now the plane's going again and now we're now,
we fucking come around and he's sitting there fucking,
he's in my ear and at this point I am lat,
like to fucking laugh.
He had me doing the podcast.
That's what I'm doing.
And he's sitting there going,
I,
he goes,
you know what?
I'm glad.
I'm glad you,
I hope you fucking do.
I hope you fucking try something.
I'll be fucking try something.
One more update.
I really hope you fucking try something.
And I'm just fucking like,
got busted laughing,
shaking it like what are you going to fucking do to me?
What are you going to do to me?
How are you gonna Punch me in the face?
You fucking winery jackass,
but yet fucking glasses on.
You know,
that's a federal offense.
You're going to go to jail if you do that or something.
I don't know what,
right.
So I'm just sitting in fucking laugh at the guy going,
I actually,
at one point I put my fucking little eye pillow thing on,
you know,
like going to sleep.
I had that out too when the stewardess was talking to me.
I was like putting it on is this total mind fuck.
Like I don't know what this guy is.
I'm just trying to go to Indianapolis.
I'm going to sleep.
And um,
so I got,
I got my fucking eye thing on,
right as he's sitting there threatening me,
just I was going and total passive aggressive.
It's like,
dude,
I'm so not concerned with you.
I'm literally putting a blindfold on.
All right,
so this fucking guy,
he starts going,
he goes,
yeah.
He goes,
you think you're fucking one this shitty fucking won this.
my,
you know,
my dad is my dad.
He started saying his dad,
some major CEO in Indianapolis doesn't sound like a fucking made up story.
I swear to God,
this is all true.
He Goes,
Mike,
my dad is some,
a major CEO in Indianapolis and I'll have you fucking arrested.
And The lady turns around again.
How have you fucking rested the second weekend on the ground?
I'm thinking like,
for what?
For what?
Sitting here,
you fucking loser.
Learn how to hold your alcohol.
All right.
And he starts describing the view that I'm going to have when I go to jail,
like some fucking law and order episode.
Oh,
you're gonna love it.
You'll be able to see Lucas oil field and bothered by the bar.
And I'm just sitting there cracking up laughing and then there's this pause,
right?
And I'm thinking finally he finally shut the fuck up.
It's like a three,
four minute pause.
He finally just gave up because I wasn't giving him anything.
I was just laughing and shaking my head.
I was being a dick to them.
I was cause I was enjoying it.
And then there was like a three minute pause and then all of a sudden he just
goes,
why are you doing the Indianapolis Bill?
So we're like 20 minutes into the flight
and am I going to be honest,
he's,
my adrenaline was so going during all of that because I knew I didn't do
anything wrong,
but I thought we were literally going to go back and there was going to be
fucking cops there.
And if like,
if,
if the fucking stewardess or the pilot asked me who I am and where I'm going,
I'm going to tell him I respect your authority.
You're just some Jay.
I don't,
you don't have any fucking authority.
I don't have to answer your questions.
It was pro was one of the most
fun experiences I've ever had with another human being.
Like when somebody thinks that they have power and you know,
they don't,
and all they can do
okay
is try just keep bluffing and raising their voices,
start cursing at you.
And if you just start laughing at them,
the look on their face is fucking priceless.
So,
okay,
blessing.
He said,
he said,
why are you going to Indianapolis Bill?
Right.
And I fucking started howling,
just fucking holding my stomach,
shaking my head
and with my fucking eye pillow thing on right.
And I know I'm going to get a ton of shit that I wear one of those eye,
they're fucking underrated.
Get the one at Brookstone where it's literally a pillow.
I'm telling you,
you could fall asleep 12 noon facing the sun.
It's awesome.
So anyways,
like after he asked me what,
what,
you know where you're going to bill you liked it was like a 10 minute,
like probably 10 minutes had gone by and I can't fucking sleep because it's so
fun and in me,
I can't wait to tell the story.
Every comic I know,
I can't wait to try it on stage to see if it's funny or whatever.
Uh,
so finally I just like,
Oh fuck it.
Maybe I'll just get on my computer and I
okay
bring up my pillow and I like,
I got to look at the guy,
cause I know he's fucking staring at me,
waiting for me to do something right.
So I lifted it up,
I get my fucking Mona Lisa smile going and I look over at the guy and dude,
he is fucking passed out.
He looked like he got shot.
He was sitting there like his head was just hanging straight down and anytime
the plane move like his head was,
I mean he looked like you got knocked out for the rest of the fucking flight.
All fucking uh oh.
What's Matt Damon's character?
Jack Ryan.
Hold fucking Jack Ryan over here.
It's just,
you know the sky marshal the fucking booze bag and God knows what else he was
on.
He was just completely out passed out for the rest of the fucking flight.
And this is why I want you to dick.
I am.
I was having so much fun with this guy.
I start,
I can't sleep.
So I start slamming waters because I want to have to get up and take a piss just
to see if this guy's going to freak out because it's security risk is getting
up.
And this is,
the joke was on me.
He never regained consciousness.
And then I really had to take a Piss,
but I'm such a stubborn fuck.
I was holding it because I wanted to make sure he was awake when I got up
because I was going to give them a little smirk and then I was going to get up.
He hit the call button again.
Um,
but he did,
he didn't wake up till we hit the ground and um,
and it's funny.
Then he woke up and it was like four hours later.
So now he had kind of slip off whatever the,
this guy was on.
Okay.
And I'm sitting there smart and waiting for the guy to start talking and he
won't look at me and I,
I,
and I think at that point he kind of fucking realize that maybe he got a little,
uh,
a little extra little too patriotic.
So we stop,
we stop at the gate and everything and we're going to get up.
So I grabbed my shit.
I get up and I'm just kinda looking at him and he won't look at me.
And then the lady who was sitting in front of me,
I had this big smile on her face.
She goes,
how are you?
how you doing?
I don't want good.
I go that I go,
that was an interesting one.
And I said it really loud.
So the guy heard and he didn't say anything,
and this is what he did to try to save face.
His pillow was kind of stuck behind this kind of stuck behind his shoulder and
like a weird place.
So he was frustrated with it.
So he ripped it out from behind him and kind of threw it down on the floor when
he tried to do some caveman grunts to try to still have some sort of a,
I don't know what.
So,
so that was my flight to Indianapolis people.
Um,
you know what,
how,
how far into the fucking podcast are we?
That was a long,
that was a long fucking story.
That did not take me a half hour to tell that did it.
Bull Shit.
I was talking,
oh,
I talking about the cheesecake factory lady.
I gotta I gotta do a little advertising here.
Um,
hold on,
hold on.
Then after the commercial break,
this is what I'm doing cause that's,
we type in my password here.
Um,
I'm going to tell you how I met Burt from sesame street and I did not have a
good experience with him either.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
A stamps.com everybody,
uh,
you know the deal.
Um,
okay.
Some small companies think that leasing a postage is postage meter is how
business and businesses get posted for their letters and packages,
but they don't realize that there's a better way.
stamps.com unlike a postage meter,
stamps.com has no hidden fees like meter inked charges or reset fees.
No longterm contracts,
no extra hardware to buy or lease.
stamps.com could save you up to 80% compared to a postage meter.
Plus with stamps.com you could do more.
You could do more than you can with a meter.
Sorry.
Um,
use your existing ad address book,
send tracking information to receipt to recipients with the click of a button.
The choices clear stamps.com offers more features at a fraction of the cost.
I use stamps.com to send out all my DVDs to all my gigs.
It's an absolute dream.
I love it.
I love not having to go to the post office.
I love being able to,
to,
to weigh it and,
and,
and put the just,
I can do it whenever I want to in the morning.
If I feel like getting my DVDs ready to go,
I could do it.
It's awesome.
Um,
use my last name bur bur for my special offer,
a no risk trial plus $110 bonus bonus offer includes a digital scale and up to
$55 in free postage.
Don't wait,
go to.com.
Before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
[inaudible] [inaudible] all right,
so the first Gig I have of the weekend,
I'm doing the Egyptian theater in downtown Indianapolis.
And um,
and basically the Egyptian theater is this beautiful place where they have two
theaters.
Uh,
they got one big one in one small one.
So I'm in the small one up on the third floor and on the big one is Elmo from
sesame street with all like kids,
superstar friends and all that,
all the p cookie,
monster,
big bird,
you know,
all the usual k like Ocean's 11 of muppets.
Right.
And um,
so what was really cool was we actually had to walk by there backstage area,
you know,
if you took the stairs before we went upstairs to where we were at.
So I went back,
I'm walking by the backstage area and there's Bert standing there and there's
the count.
He's sitting like sitting down like the makeup thing and there's big bird and
all these,
all these people that I recognize.
So I take out my cell phone camera,
I'm like,
oh my God,
there they are.
And I'm like fell modem and stuff.
And all of a sudden birch starts waving at me.
They're like,
hey bird,
are you doing,
I love your brother thinking all this stuff,
right?
And he starts walking towards me with his big head and I was like,
oh my God,
he's coming over.
I got to get a picture with this guy and all of a sudden birches starts tugging
at the door,
trying to sell,
trying to slam it in my face,
and then he couldn't get it closed.
And then he just walked away shrugging his shoulders and I'm thinking of what
the fuck.
But evidently they have a rule.
You can't film or take pictures of them because of the little kids see them
without their heads on or if somebody gets out of the big bird costume and they,
they just see it hanging there with nobody in it.
And I guess it's really fucking traumatic.
But,
uh,
I got the video of it that we're going to put up on the,
the Monday morning podcast page.
It's hilarious because now that you know the story,
when you see Bert waving at me,
you'll see how I confused his way.
He,
I thought he was waving hello,
but he was waving like,
no,
Nah,
no photos.
And he k walk it over.
Um,
I actually got nervous with his big head.
I think I say,
holy crap.
When he came up to me,
I couldn't believe how big his fucking head was.
And then he just starts tugging on the door.
But the stopper wouldn't let them close or whatever,
you know,
it is.
That's one of the ones you got to watch the video for that to be funny.
Fucking Burke.
What a cunt.
You know,
I thought that was just his character on the show.
Evidently he's like that offstage to,
um,
all right,
let's get on with the podcast here.
Um,
by the way,
people,
if I'm going to read the emails for this week and if you'd like to send a,
uh,
an email to the,
to the Monday morning podcast asks me questions,
tell me to go fuck myself.
Uh,
the email is bill at the [inaudible] podcast.com and,
uh,
whatever,
send it to us and if we like what you wrote,
we do get a lot of them sit.
Don't get offended if we don't get to yours,
but,
um,
you know,
your emails are 50% of this podcast.
The other 50% is me running my mouth about my,
my fucking life here.
All right.
First one of the week.
Best man speech.
Dear bill,
I am going to be a best man at my friend's wedding in a few weeks and I am
absolutely shitting myself.
What advice could you give to someone who is terrified of public speaking to not
make a dick out of myself.
Thank you.
And Go fuck yourself.
All right.
What advice would I give you?
All right dude,
if you're this nervous,
that means you're not going to be good.
All right.
Which means you're not going to want to remember your horrific speech.
So what I would do is just start drinking like heavily.
No,
I'm fucking with you.
Um,
what should you do?
Well,
the thing is,
you're so busy focusing on how you don't want to go up there and do it,
that that's probably what's causing you to not know what to say.
All right.
I,
what I would do if I was you is I would sit down and just write down what you
would like to say to your buddy who's getting married.
Like,
if you were at a bar,
what you would want,
what you would say to him if there wasn't a bunch of people looking,
you know,
we say,
listen man,
you think it's great if I'm this girl,
I'm really happy for you.
You know,
I love you man.
Like whatever the fuck you want to say.
And then just have that down.
And this,
this is the bottom line.
Like,
it's just a bunch of indie crowd is just a bunch of individuals.
They're not organized.
They're not a union.
You know,
you didn't,
uh,
you know,
take the last morsels of food and they just found out that they're all going to
starve to death.
You read if you're at a happy event,
everybody's excited.
Everybody wants you to do well.
Do you know,
you know what you have to do to yourself to actually not do well in this,
this Gig?
It's impossible to fuck it up unless you go out and fuck it up.
All right?
Don't overthink it.
Just say what you'd love to say to the guy.
You know,
it's going to be fine.
But,
uh,
I would try to do it stone sober because you don't,
you don't want to be a,
you don't wanna be all slurring and I'll,
you know
this,
this is a pressure gig.
You know why I do it?
Because this is only going to get married once,
hopefully.
So if you fuck this up,
you're really,
you're going to get a nickname out of this.
Are they?
Every time you guys go drink and they're going to fucking talk about how you
fucked it up.
So I guess that that's why you're nervous and I probably should have brought
that up cause I probably just made you more nervous.
All right.
You know what?
Fucking stop being a pussy man up.
You've done book reports before,
right?
Just fucking man up.
Getting mad at yourself for being such a fucking that.
There's people right now,
they're,
they're getting tortured around the world.
People who sewed together at like four in
the fucking morning,
you know,
and what do you have to do?
You gonna have to give a fucking speech,
but how much you liked somebody in front of a bunch of people who want it to go
well before you get to go to an open bar and started drinking.
Huh?
This is what makes you nervous.
You sir,
need to grow a Dick.
All right.
In a pair of fucking bulls and get the damn job done.
We hear it.
The Monday morning podcast.
Believe in you.
Do not disappoint us.
There you go.
Now go out in the field and you make me prayer.
You make this school proud.
You make your mommy and daddy perhaps.
Um,
all right,
well paid girlfriend Chili.
Billy Burke,
my girlfriend of one year is about to graduate from a major university until you
hit the lottery.
Very nice and became a type of bioscientist starting out at 80 grand a year.
Holy Shit Dude.
Through there should be like ticker tape fallen down around her fucking pussy.
I'm sorry that was disrespectful.
This isn't some girl you just bang.
This is your girlfriend.
I'm sorry.
I'm just saying,
dude,
he hit the lottery.
You know,
every time she walks in the house,
it's easy to here,
done that.
I
just march around behind her,
that and that,
uh,
my girlfriend and shit.
Uh,
with that type of career and her intelligence,
her salary,
we're only go up from there.
I worked the front desk at a hotel in a small town.
I'm not going to say the state making nowhere near that.
Oh God.
Here we go.
Now a bunch of women are getting mad right now.
See that is,
see that they just can't handle it.
Their egos cannot have a fucking sex.
That's how I,
um,
this is why you know why that is ladies?
Because you're basically doing our job.
What would you do with one day your man came home and he was suddenly sexier
than you and could actually give birth to a baby when you feel fucking useless
at that point,
you know,
if a woman is making way more money than you are,
I mean,
all she has to do is just go to the gym with you and our bench press you.
And then that's it.
I mean,
you're officially not even a man anymore like it.
This isn't really about the woman.
All right?
This is about a guy where it's just like,
okay,
so you're going to provide and you can have the baby,
then I might as well be a fucking wooden Indian over here holding cigars because
I'm useless.
You know what I mean?
Come on ladies.
You know the deal.
Don't you want to feel like you're needed?
You know,
I mean Jesus Christ,
this guy at this point,
he's,
he's a fucking Kardashians.
His job is just to stand there and look good.
So anyways,
he says,
I'm a well traveled guy without a college degree and an ambition of larger
ambition,
larger than the job market,
but I'm happy.
Well,
there you go,
dude.
You won.
You didn't waste all your money going to college.
You know,
I think you know,
if,
if he,
if you major in as a bioscientist,
but what the fuck is she going to do?
Huh.
Helps some corporation come up with some bugs they can spray and some poor
people so they can get the oil in the ground.
You know?
Well how are you going to bio science,
scientific arena in it and it doesn't end up being something
evil.
You know,
you guys hear that disgusting sound in the background.
Is My dog licking her paws.
She fucking,
she hurt her foot.
We've got this God damn cage that's made out of like fucking plutonium that was
supposed to be pitbull proof.
She's such a fucking maniac.
It's like if we just leave her alone in the house,
she freaks out cause she has separation anxiety cause some Douche beat her and
left her by a river.
Right?
So if he leave her alone in here,
she tries to clot to the house and at this point she could cause there's so many
fucking holes in it.
All right,
so we were told to get like one of these little kid,
they call him Cassius.
It's a fucking cage.
You put them in a cage.
Now they don't feel overwhelmed that they have to protect the whole house is
just this little area,
this thing.
I swear to God,
it's made out of like rebar or something.
The other day she ripped a fucking Pete one of the bars off and this is what I'd
love.
She buried it under a bed,
you know,
like she's Tim Robinson,
Shawshank slowly digging a hole and he's got the Marilyn Monroe fucking for
whatever poster it was Rita Hayworth.
Um,
so whatever.
She's over there licking her wounds.
It's funny as hell.
I literally carry her down the street,
let her go to the bathroom,
and then I bring her back and then I take out the little fucking looks like an
oxy pad.
Like she has acne and I have to wipe down or pause.
It's getting better for everybody.
Feels bad.
She's fine.
She's a pitbull fucking maniac.
She so gets into the goal,
going to get addie chipping teeth and shit.
She's nuts.
Fucking nuts.
But I swear to God,
her work ethic is incredible.
She plays hurt,
you know,
just like Jordan.
Um,
anyways,
where,
where am I here?
He said,
I do love this girl,
but I don't want to find myself.
Three years down the road getting dumped for not being her financial equal.
I'm pretty successful with the ladies.
So it's not like I can't find another female who I can connect with and lead a
happy middle class life.
She has a passion for goats.
She wants a farm and I can really see enjoying the farm life.
No more shitty boss,
no more a shitty ass hole.
Customer bullshit growing food,
learning trades,
carving out my own way.
I've talked to her about the money thing and she responded by saying,
why would you worry about that?
We'll do that was going to be my advice.
Just just say that,
you know,
tell her.
And she says she's not worried about it yet until she gets fucking laid off and
you're over there wiggling in the corner.
Um,
he said,
money is such a small priority to me.
I don't care how much you make,
as long as you contribute me making so much,
does it mean I'll have more money?
Just more goats,
a cleo knock it off,
which I know she truly means right now.
Uh,
but right now she isn't making $100,000 a year living with some Schmo who's
grinding it out for an hourly wage.
Life takes you places you don't expect.
So she may shelf the farm life for a legitimate career,
doing whatever she decides,
which would lead me pretty much incapable of contributing a solid share towards
the standard of life that she is capable of living all.
If you guys leave your hypothetical farm,
okay,
um,
I would have left already,
but I don't want to prematurely fuck up a great thing just because I'm insecure.
Well that's,
you know,
something that's very perceptive.
You know,
dude,
you're not that bad man.
You,
you analyze yourself,
you see all your fucking things up,
you know,
and you know what makes you happy.
You're in a great place right now.
Anyways,
she's crazy about me and I'm pretty crazy about her,
but I'm a real,
but I am a realistic,
real,
a realist.
And logic tells me then a potentially step,
just a stepping stone in our very successful future.
Look,
dude,
if she's fucking crazy about you and your,
you saying you're pretty crazy about her,
if you weren't so insecure,
I think you'd be crazy about her to,
uh,
you want to ride this one out.
All right.
And,
um,
look,
there's that lady who went the fucking cheesecake factory or her husband and I
guess her husband's an architect.
He did design the house.
All right.
That was a bad example.
Listen to,
um,
okay.
I Dunno.
I like,
well,
here's one for you.
What if this relationship would've worked out but your insecurity,
you kicked it to the curb and then fucking,
you know,
15 years later you're in your late thirties.
Okay.
Just broke up with somebody else drinking the local IPA.
Just go and like,
you know,
a judge day with,
oh,
I had this beauty back in the day.
Fuck that.
If you've got a beautiful girl and she's crazy about you and your crazy about
her and she's gonna make a great fucking living like,
dude,
women are way more forgiving of that.
Um,
look,
if you get yourself like one of these fucking plastic surgery faced whores from
the,
uh,
these reality shows,
yeah,
that's going to be an issue.
But like,
you know,
as I,
I think women did,
they're very forgiving as long as you're working towards something and you're a
happy guy if you like.
I Dunno when you're dating,
it's very hard to find somebody that's happy and you come home and they were in
a good mood and they want to do some fun stuff.
Um,
that's kind of way more important than making a fuck load of money,
believe it or not.
I mean,
once you can pay your bills and you can eat more money doesn't necessarily make
you happier.
Um,
beyond a certain point.
I know a lot of people just rolled their fucking eyes,
but I'm just saying like,
okay,
you know,
I don't know that that's a whole,
that's also a whole other conversation about how to use money.
So you're not imprisoning yourself.
I mean,
a lot of fucking people,
more money,
you know,
that dumb song or that dumb analogy.
More money,
more problems.
Um,
okay.
You know?
Yeah.
Because you're going down to the fucking titty bar with money hanging out of
your pocket dump and crystal all over a rug in front of people who work in
cubicles.
Well,
hustle on a fucking corner,
you know?
Okay.
And that's how he ended up having lawsuits.
I mean,
you know,
you make a fuck load of money,
eventually you're gonna have a lawsuit or something,
but like,
you know,
more titty bars,
more problems is really what it is.
Like if you,
if you make a,
you don't have to make that fucking much money.
If you go out and you buy a house that you can afford,
and I don't mean the mortgage.
If you can afford to kick the shit out of the principal,
the principal,
um,
that's,
that's the way to go.
Even then they can still fuck with you.
It's,
it's so God damn evil.
The whole fucking thing is evil.
I Dunno.
What did you well,
Geez,
that was uplifting,
wasn't it?
Um,
I don't know,
sir.
If you,
if you have some sort of a fucking dream,
I would,
if,
if you're,
if you're making steps every day working towards that and k and she's,
uh,
she's the person you saying that she is,
she's not going to have a problem with you.
All right.
Don't fuck it up.
Stay in it.
All right.
Open.
Yeah.
Hah.
Find Love Buddy.
All right.
Okay.
Custody issue in Norway.
Bill,
I'm a guy from Norway,
23 years old and have two children.
Oh yeah,
they already five foot 10.
Everybody over there is like fucking six,
nine.
Um,
excuse my writing if it's wrong.
No,
it's not,
dude,
you're,
you're writing is incredible.
You're writing in a second language and I'm willing to guess that you probably
know a little Swedish.
And I know that you guys and you guys can come.
Okay.
No,
I think Norwegian was the different,
it's different one,
I think Norway and Denmark,
they can understand each other and then Norway,
it gets a little funky.
But whatever.
I'm sure if you are already bilingual,
you're probably trilingual.
So,
um,
I'm amazed at that.
So here we go.
I'm not writing into any fucker Norwegian podcast in Norwegian.
Okay.
You Win Sir.
All right,
my problem is that my ex has Jesus Christ.
Dude,
you have lived a life 23,
two kids.
My ex wife lab,
the JJ,
Bryce.
Uh,
my problem is my ex has my two children away from me.
We had an agreement that we would have them 50,
50 oral agreement of Jesus Christ.
After a little while I lost my job because the company had a rough time with the
economy.
Now wait a minute,
I thought you guys economy was great over there cause you had all the oil.
Anyways,
he goes,
so they had to cut some costs out from the firm.
So now I live on the money that I get from welfare until I get a new job.
Tough.
Okay.
Tough marked
in Norway now.
Too many immigrants taking our jobs.
Yeah.
You know where the immigrants are,
the Swedes.
Look at me.
I'm fucking well traveled.
I know what goes on in the world.
I got something to add.
Anyways.
My income is a little bit lower than it was before and now I'm struggling paying
our debt from the time,
from the time we lived together.
As a result of that,
she says,
I can't see my children before I can pay my debt.
Oh my God.
What a fucking cunt.
Okay.
Wow.
Dude.
You know something.
That detail right there.
I see why he got a divorce.
First of all,
congratulations for getting away from that woman just kicking you when you're
down.
Okay.
You know,
or maybe she's bitter from the divorce,
but good Lord.
Anyways,
he says to me,
she's punishing the children by not letting them see their father because I lost
my job.
Don't you agree?
Absolutely.
That is 100% fucking selfish.
She's using the children as punishment and reward like their,
like their cookies.
They're human beings and they need to see their dad.
And you know,
I imagine a 23,
I'm willing to bet that they're still pretty young.
So they're at a critical point of this psychological development where they
need,
they need a father there as long as the mother [inaudible] where the fuck did I
pull that one from?
You think I had kids?
Um,
anyways,
he says this has nothing to do with the children whatsoever.
This is a problem between her and me.
But that's not the worst part.
This fucking lady is now claiming child support.
She takes the children away from me,
although I am fully capable of having them.
I give them shelter,
food,
clothes,
you name it.
But still she takes them away and fucking claims child support from me because I
have problems paying out some debt.
Uh,
we had when we were still together.
How in the world can I pay child support when I have a hard time paying our
debt?
You see,
she's trying to rob me for my money and takes my children too fucking cunt.
Absolutely.
So I've talked to my lawyer and I'm fucking going to court for this shit.
You can try as much as you want to break me,
but in fucked me up.
But don't ever take my kids.
Don't ever fuck with my kids.
All right.
I liked this.
He's going,
it sounds like the beginning of a Stallone movie.
You're a good man and you've been wronged,
but instead of the movies,
you can't take it in your own hands.
You got to get a lawyer.
All right.
Um,
would love it if you could read this in the podcast so everybody can hear it.
More things need to come,
come out in the media about this.
Absolutely.
Love your podcast.
Please come to Norway soon and have some shows.
Uh,
absolutely.
I was actually talking to,
uh,
the people over.
Um,
I've been talking to some people over there trying to put together some shows.
it's been a little over a year since I've been there,
so I got a whole new hour stuff.
Um,
I absolutely love going over there.
And this time when I go over,
I think,
uh,
maybe I'm gonna stop and Switzerland or France or Italy or something like that.
Maybe Spain on the way back,
you know,
have a great fucking time.
But yeah,
now more,
more needs to come out about this.
Like,
okay,
look,
I understand that she's upset.
Maybe she feels like you didn't hold up your end of the bargain because you,
you,
you can't pay what you were paying.
And she finally just said,
fuck this.
But you know,
the lesson here is you have to get stuff in writing.
If you don't get it in writing,
you're,
you're going to end up in the situation you're in.
You probably still would end up going to court anyways,
but at least you'd have some,
a piece of paper that could,
uh,
back up your,
your verbal agreement.
So a good luck to you,
sir.
I'm sorry you're going through that and um,
okay.
I Dunno.
Is there any way to sit down with her and just lot just say,
listen,
I understand that you're upset with me.
I understand.
You know that me getting laid off is hurting us financially,
but like we can't,
you know,
we can't use the kids.
We have to do what's best for the kids.
And it's not good for them to not see their mother or their father.
Okay?
Jesus Christ.
Hell hath no fury.
Um,
Granola bitches.
Uh,
Bilbo Bergen's,
my wife,
he has gone granola like a mofo since we got married and she's discovered all
natural makeup and hair treatments.
She has started washing your hair with baking soda and an oils leaving her hair
stringy and ratty,
but according to her feeling good,
fell Jesus also,
she stopped shaving her legs,
plucking her eyebrows.
She doesn't brush her teeth at night and only showers every other day because
she says it's all good for her skin.
She's not a fatty and is a great person,
but when it comes time to throw down in the booth booth duar
she smells like a sweaty Hobo and it makes me grit my teeth.
Oh yeah,
do
okay?
He says,
I'm certainly not a Kong Dong,
but she always gets worn out for sex.
It doesn't recover for days.
This guy's fucking hilarious.
A calm down.
All right.
Needless to say,
even after I tell her she smells crazy,
she still does all of this.
Oh,
see you're telling her that she smells like a fucking,
oh boy.
I love Hobo.
Hobo.
So better,
so much better than homeless guy.
Hobo.
It's like you smell like fucking the depression.
You don't smell like the dust bowl.
Um,
I'm on the verge of freaking out and going strictly all hand or Lilly or leaving
it or leaving her it.
I'm not sure what to do and I'm sure you can't share it,
but any feedback would be great.
Pine away and go fuck yourself.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
MMM.
All right.
This is what I would do.
Okay.
The next time she wants to have sex,
I'd say,
hang on a second.
Okay.
No,
first,
this is what I do.
First thing I would do,
I would go down to the hardware store.
Yeah.
And I would buy as many garden hoses is you needed to connect together from the
side of the house.
All right.
Um,
well,
maybe dad's going to cost you too much money to make your point the next time
she wants to throw down,
just somehow get her outside and say,
yeah,
hang on a second and just fucking turn the hose on it.
Dude,
I don't,
I don't know what to tell you.
I,
I don't,
I don't know.
This is a deal breaker.
Okay?
You gotta be like,
Lady,
you fucking,
you smell like fucking 2000 BC.
I might as well be fucking you in a cave with a,
with Molly or the woolly mammoth.
Bbds on
you smell like you should be holding a spear.
How else do I put this?
You know,
you should be squatting down,
banging a rock on some berries.
That's,
that's what you fucking,
you smell your pussy smells prehistoric.
Even back in the day,
I'm sure you know,
even if I smelled the way I smelled Jason,
a saber tooth tiger across the fucking planes,
you know,
if you smelled like this,
I would drag you down to some prehistoric river and Dunky when they're like five
fucking times before I bench over a rock.
I'm trying to tell you.
You fucking smell,
dude.
This is like,
that's like disgusting.
Okay.
It is bad.
His guys could smell.
At least our shit can get a little breeze on it.
You know,
you don't want a woman's smells stinky pussies.
Like it's like hockey stuff.
It's zipped up in that fucking bag and when she on
she on zips it,
you could smell it from across the room.
All right.
A guy's fucking smelly junk.
I mean,
that's like a,
that's like old fruit on the table.
Just flies buzzing around and shit.
Still disgusting.
But you know what I mean?
It's not as fucking bad.
Okay.
Look what's going to smell worse?
A dead body laying on the side of the street.
Oh,
one locked in the trunk.
All right.
If I made my fucking point,
how's it down?
How's it fucking down?
Dude?
I don't know what to tell you.
It's just I,
I,
you know what I would do?
I would just say,
listen,
I'm not having sex with you until you wash yourself properly.
Okay?
They make all kinds of all natural soaps.
There's no excuse for the way you smell right now.
You are a fucking train wreck.
Jesus Christ.
Why don't you just start shooting drugs while you're at it to add another level
of ski Venus to this Korean.
Let me show you something.
Look at my deck.
You see what it's doing?
You see what it's doing right now?
It's not interest.
It's not finding the floors.
Fascinating.
Okay.
It's depressed right now.
That's why it appears to be looking at the fine grain of our hardwood floors.
Look at my Dick.
Look at it.
That's what you do to me.
All right,
dude,
I don't,
I don't know what to tell you.
If you got to tell her to fucking Washer God damn ass,
you know I,
I would just get like,
I would get really passive aggressive.
I would get one of those little spray bottles and I would have some perfume in
there and not the all natural kind either.
No,
you don't.
You got to be obnoxious.
You got to get the old school and that has that little pumper on it and just
anytime it don't spray it on or just anytime she walks by,
just spray it.
And when she looks at it,
he'd just be like,
you,
you smell horribly
in that smell is is,
it's getting on the love that I,
that I have for you in every day.
It's,
it's like,
you know what my love,
if you could draw it looks like the roof on bill Burt's house.
Alright.
Stripper oil.
Hey Man.
Basically I was in a strip club and rub some oil on the strippers.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Well,
I hope you would dress like Walter White when you did it.
He goes,
my girlfriend knew I was going and was totally cool about it.
When I let it slip that I rubbed oil on them,
she went crazy,
said it was the same as cheating and she can never trust me again.
It's clearly not the same as cheating,
but she won't listen to me.
Any advice would be greatly appreciated.
Uh,
this is what you have to understand.
You know when,
uh,
I understand what she's saying,
like,
look,
if you're girl was going to go see the fucking a Ding Dong review,
whatever the fuck they chip and Dales.
Right,
okay.
And they were just fucking up there shaking their dicks on the stage and every,
they're all gone
fucking freaking out.
Whatever the fuck it is they do.
Okay.
You could probably get past that,
but what if she put some oil on her hand and started grabbing his fucking taught
little butt cheek there or even worse fucking uh,
grabbed his dick.
Gave it a little up down.
Huh?
What would you send me?
Like,
it's not the same thing.
This is a bunch of people watching.
There's nothing in a minute.
It's fucking silly.
You would definitely have a problem with that.
This is what I would say to her.
I'd say,
listen,
I want to apologize for my behavior.
I wasn't clear where the line was and just say that I actually put myself in
your position.
If you went to a mail review and did what I did,
I would be offended too.
I apologize.
What can I do to make it up to you?
Just totally put it on yourself.
I understand what you're saying that it's not,
it's not cheating,
but it is you putting your hand,
you'll,
you got oiled up hands.
It's bad enough you putting your hands on some of the girl's ass.
Your Hands Are All oiled up,
but you can tell in defense of you,
you can say,
listen,
I sewed,
didn't think that it was cheating that I told you that I did it.
You know,
which is probably bad.
Had I known I was cheating,
then I would allied and said I didn't do it then I don't listen to me.
I'm a fucking moron.
But there,
there,
there was something worth listening to when there wasn't there at some point.
Oh Jesus.
And Hour in three fucking minutes and well,
this was a fun ass podcast from me.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
Um,
real quick before I get outta here,
if you would like to donate to the wonderful Monday morning podcast,
it's very simple thing you can do.
You Go,
do you go to [inaudible] dot com he click on the podcast page and you'll see an
Amazon banner ad and you just click on that.
It's basically anytime.
Anytime you want to buy something on amazon.com there's a way that you can,
you can go to amazon.com and donate to this podcast.
Go to [inaudible] dot com click on the [inaudible] podcast page,
click on the banner ad,
and then you go right to you.
Go right to Amazon.
All right.
And nothing costs you anymore.
They're just paying me because I'm driving traffic to their site.
They kicked me a little bit of money and then I take a percentage of that and I
kick it over to the wounded warriors project.
So not only support me,
you support in the tropes.
Okay.
It is a win win.
Um,
so that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
I'm trying to see if there was anything else I wanted to talk about.
I think that was pretty much it.
Uh,
I want to thank everybody by the way.
Um,
these were exceptionally great crowds this weekend,
um,
in Indianapolis and Minneapolis is just a whole other level.
Like I've heard forever that they're one of the great comedy crowds out there
and um,
you know,
I could never get booked at that,
that their comedy club out there,
they just had so many,
so many going on was so many great comics wanted to play there and I wasn't high
enough on the ladder so I never got to do a club date.
I did a bunch of college dates,
Duluth,
you know,
and all these other fucking places.
I went to the mall of America and I rode the roller coaster by myself.
Um,
just to explore that level of loneliness.
I've been to Minnesota,
I've been to a vikings game when Randy Moss was still there,
I went to a twins game at the homer dome when they played with,
when cal Ripken was still playing.
All right.
I went to a wild game.
I went to the target center and I saw the fucking timble worlds when Kevin
Gannet was still playing there.
I have been to Minnesota,
but I never got to perform in front of adults.
It was always a young adults.
It was always doing college gigs.
And uh,
I used to love doing that shit out there.
Like when there was times like you'd fly into the city and then you had the
option of jumping on a smaller plane,
like,
you know,
if you land in Omaha and then flying out to grand junction or flying out to
fucking God.
I used to know the names of these obscure places that I went to.
Um,
I used to do this gig every,
got a year up to the upper peninsula of Michigan and I used to always drive it.
I'd fly into Detroit or into Chicago depending on what part of the peninsula was
on.
And I drove it cause I wanted to see what it looked like,
you know?
And um,
I know a lot of people like,
you know,
there's was no love to see you out there.
It's still fucking awesome when you get a perspective of how fucking big this
country is.
And uh,
how many people were,
how many animals?
I can't imagine what it used to look like before the white man came and fucked
it all up.
Um,
Paul,
the herds of buffalo and all that title,
I'm into that type of shit.
You know,
all the native Americans,
what the fuck they were doing.
You know,
although I don't buy 100% that native Americans were just,
you know,
just cause cause white people fucking committed genocide that they're
automatically the saints.
You know,
like there was no native American date rapist dragging some woman into his TP.
they had have been some of them that were scumbags.
I mean the human beings,
right.
Some of us are good,
some of us are bad,
you know,
look at them now they're all in gambling.
That's a piece of shit industry.
What the fuck I'm talking about?
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
Thank you so much for listening.
Oh,
coming up.
By the way,
y'all lived down the dirty south.
You,
would you like to come out and see bill burr,
that crazy motherfucker via over coming down y a couple of weeks.
I got my dirty south tour.
All right,
I'm going to be a,
where the fuck are the dates?
There they are.
April 9th.
I'm going to be in Georgia.
Whoa.
Georgia,
Georgia theater in Athens,
Georgia with Paul Dude.
I called it [inaudible] and uh,
Jason Law head.
And if you're lucky,
if you call out,
maybe Jason I'll do is fucking Reggie Jackson.
He'll do as Reggie Jay.
He's got to do it for somebody on that tour.
You got to see his fucking Reggie.
It's amazing.
Uh,
or is Dave Parker if you're an old baseball,
his Willie McGee,
he's going to kill me cause you guys are gonna yell on that shit out.
Instead of listening to his fucking act.
Do me a favor.
Wait till he gets towards the end.
Uh,
then I'm gonna be doing with a comedy club at this dome in Hoover,
Alabama.
Um,
then I'm at the Charles Charleston Music Hall,
Charleston,
South Carolina.
Then I'm doing two shows at the Tabernacle in Atlanta,
Georgia.
And those that that's the ninth 10th 11th 12th.
All right.
Georgia on the Ninth Alabama on the 10th.
Charleston,
south on the 11th Atlanta,
Georgia on the 12th he is my life.
On the eighth I'm going to the NCAA final game and on the 13th I'm going to the
masters.
Go Fuck Yourself.
All right.
There you go.
There's your motivation for the week.
Go after your dream man.
Get out of that cubicle.
Um,
oh.
And then the following week,
the southern tour continues when I go into this shady as state in the union
other than Alaska,
I go to Florida.
Monday,
April 15th I'm at the Tampa Improv for two shows.
The 16th I got to college date,
I've believe that's close to the Public Florida State University.
I'll have to figure that out.
And then on the 17th I'm on the Jackie,
I'm at the Jackie Gleason theater in Miami,
Florida.
And um,
I can't wait to do these dates.
That's going to be a run of 10 shows over like nine days or some shit.
Is that what it is?
Uh,
what's,
what's nine eight days over eight days?
Oh my God,
it's gonna be fucking,
it's going to be phenomenal.
I had the hard copy version of my new special.
Pretty soon we will be selling that up here on the website.
That is it.
Go fuck yourselves as the podcast for this week.
I will talk to you guys a little later.
I'll talk to you next week.
Please keep the emails coming.
I'll see you.